today we're doing the oldest number
system in the world
babylonian cuneiform numbers
cuneiform yeah it's true i thought it
was
uniform too but then i went i spoke to
one of the curators of the cuneiform
collection at the british museum
and in this first sentence out his mouth
has said cuneiform
so that's how one should say it so the
first
writing system is cuneiform and it
evolved about three thousand years bc
between the tigris and the euphrates the
kind of sumerian
civilization
and what it is it's bits of mud you make
a mark
using a reed although here i've got a
lollipop stick and i've got some potty
putty
but it's essentially the same cunes is
the latin for wedge and it's all about
making
wedge marks so when you see it written
down
you see with like little triangles and
lines but that's just because they're
trying to make it look like an actual 3d
wedge mark but today
i'm going to be able to show you using
actual 3d wedge marks
so the system of writing things down
emerge around about 3000 bc
but i'm going to sort of speed forward
to about 2000 bc
when the number system was already kind
of in fully functioning order
and kind of worked and pretty much the
oldest kind of mathematical tablets that
we have
are from that period and it's you call
that babylon so it's the kind of
civilization
that kind of came on after suma so how
do babylonian
numbers work well i'm going to take
one of my tablets and i think which is
interesting
all the tablets that were used to make
uniform on are really about this size
so often you see them in photographs and
they kind of expanded and you think well
maybe this tablet was this kind of
massive tablet like a kind of gravestone
well no they're all just about this size
almost
like a you know say half an iphone or
something
if you go to the british museum where
they have well over a hundred thousand
of these tablets they're more like this
they're kind of squarish
and there's got all the writing on it
because
how do you write it you write it by
holding the tablet in one hand and
holding the reader the other and then
making the marks
it was used over a period of 3000 years
so it's actually the writing system a
number system that has been used for the
longest period of time
much more than the latin alphabet or
roman numerals
or arabic numerals so in terms of
say what you call civilization since the
early civilizations it's been used for
two-thirds really of human history i
wonder if ours will ever overtake it or
something else will come along
or wonder if ours will ever become the
title holder
what are arabic numerals well you could
argue that um hexadecimal or even base
two has really overtaken it because we
live in a world of computers and that's
how computers work
the number system uses only two types of
wedge
one is this that's one
two is another one three
that's three four five
six seven eight nine
so one to nine you're just adding it's
quite like
roman numerals but you're just keeping
on adding the same digits
when you get to ten you use this i'm
going to turn this over
and you use the other sort of horizontal
and use that so that's 10. i want to
carry on counting you go
back to the vertical 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19
and 20 would be
sorry whoops two horizontal two
horizontals so keep on going they go to
40 50
51 52 53
54 55 56 57 58 59
and can you guess what 60 is well i
would have thought it would be
six horizontals you fell into my trap
you fell as my trap this
is 60 because you're starting off with a
system
which is adding new symbols which is
just like roman
but it also had a positional element and
when you get to 60
you move along so this should be a zero
here but the problem with the
babylonians they didn't have a symbol
for zero
later on they invented a kind of symbol
but actually they never used it in a
case like this
so that is 60 61 is this
62 63 actually
says a better 63 64 65 66
67 68 69 and 70
i mean yeah 70 would be a
160 and
a 10. it's called a sexagesimal system
i base 60. you've got this column it
counts up to 60
and then this one here whatever you have
in there you multiply by 60.
so actually just so you wanted to go
further on that number there
is three thousand six hundred
and sixty one
if you want to do 3671
you'd put like a yeah that would have
10 in there 10 would go here yeah but if
you wanted to put a 10 here
that would mean you have to times 60 by
11 which is 660.
so that would be 3600 by 660
plus 11. how would you write
3600 and one do you have to have like a
space
in that column yes so that the
babylonians
required a symbol for zero for when
there was nothing in that column yeah
and eventually they started to use
two diagonals basically like that two
diagonals
that would be 3601 with the two
to indicate nothing in the middle this
only occurred in later
babylonian mathematical texts and also
they never used it
at either side so you couldn't tell the
difference between
sort of one one zero and one one
zero zero for example and just one one
but they did use it as a marker to
separate
middle columns so you've got this really
interesting combination of a positional
system
and a sort of non-positional system and
you might think well isn't that
complicated
it might look complicated actually
for doing maths it's really good and
it's much much better than the roman
system
with the roman system you get up to m
that's a thousand and then if you want
to get more than a thousand just
keep on doing ends m's forever
whereas here if you want to get bigger
you just need to go to one new column
and then you get the next multiple of 60
up so you can actually get
very quickly to really high numbers but
also you can go the other way
like the decimal point if you were to
put a 1 here
that would be 160 and if you were to put
next to that that would be 1 3 6
hundredths
it's very good at getting big numbers
very good at dividing into small numbers
much better because the romans they use
kind of fractions it's really
complicated
and difficult to do whereas this you
could do very well
and it is no coincidence the babylonians
were the best astronomers of their age
by far
and one of the reasons is that they had
a much much better number system they
could use to do it and in fact they were
so good
that the real you know you might have
thought well why 60
60 sounds familiar the reason why we
still use base 60 when talking about the
time so 60 seconds in a minute
60 minutes in an hour is that 60 was
the number chosen as the base by the
babylonians right at the beginning
and it's because of all that kind of
stargazing etc that that even though the
greeks had a different number system the
romans did
they just kept the base 60 when talking
about time
and why did the babylonians choose 60
well this is really interesting and it's
probably one of the biggest questions in
ancient mathematics
no one knows there are two possible
explanations one
it could be that just so you're
approximating a circle
you might want to put a hexagon in it
hexagon is actually
six triangles with 60 degrees so already
just so you want to divide each sixth
into ten
then you get sixty so that's one reason
they think but why divide it into ten
are we coming back to fingers now
yes because the thing that's most
natural to do
in the way to count and there was a base
10 system
embedded in their base 60 system because
we get
just the horizontal lines until we get
to 10 when we come to this other
symbol is that here we've got the sixes
the most
natural thing to divide a circle to is
into sixth you know we got to 360
degrees
so that's interesting already we've kept
that 360 degrees
divided into six that each one is 60
degrees then maybe it's easier just to
then use your hands and divide the hand
to 10. the other reason why 60 is really
good
is that 60 is a very divisible number
the numbers that divide into 60 are 1 2
3 4 5 6
10 12 20 30 and then 60.
that's really good for doing arithmetic
in your head and also
for just dividing stuff up it's like
it's like really really useful
so that it could be that it could be a
mixture of both i mean some people think
that
60 is also 5 times 12 they could have
been a
base 5 number system because
ten that's one system they're also based
side number systems with the five
figures on our hand
and they could have been a base twelve
twelve is also a very divisible number
no one quite knows but it's interesting
that the very oldest type of number
is still present with us every day
a bit more from this interview can be
found on our second channel
numberphile2 and for lots more of this
type of stuff why not check out alex
belos's
the language lovers puzzle book there
are links in the video description
thanks also to our number file patrons
including those
whose names you're seeing on the screen
at the moment say that the
digit can be used kind of all singing or
dancing
number digit just like all the others
that was the indians
it was moving it from a kind of
placeholder to realizing that no no it
can actually behave really really well
and even when it appeared in india it
took centuries
for people to actually begin to play
around with it and realize
that you know